[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american science
fiction horror film called village of
the damned spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
midwich california is a quiet coastal
town that has nothing unique about it
until one day a strange phenomenon
occurs the people are taking part in
preparing for their annual festival when
the clock hits 10 am at this very moment
everyone in the town falls asleep
including birds and other animals some
lie unconscious in their houses and
others in the middle of the street a man
named mike is driving away from the city
at the same time when he is about to
cross the border he too falls asleep
causing his car to crash and explode
soon the incident catches the attention
of the people from the neighboring town
police and forensic doctors come to
investigate but everyone who crosses the
border falls asleep instantly after some
research they find the town is connected
to no nuclear or chemical plant that
might have caused a chemical leak that
means that whatever is happening to the
town is beyond human knowledge one of
the doctors investigating the scene is
named alan he is also a resident of the
town and is worried because his wife
barbara is not answering his calls hours
pass and at exactly 4 pm everyone wakes
up simultaneously allen rushes to
barbara and asks her what happened but
she is as confused as the rest of the
town the town's school principal jill
turns out to be mike's wife upon finding
out about his death she is heartbroken
no scientist or philosopher is able to
tell what caused the town to sleep and
then to wake up with no explanation
found life runs normally in midwich
people forget about the incident and go
about their lives for the next few weeks
then alan notices many pregnancies
happening in the town a woman named
callie who hasn't been with anyone for
over a year gets pregnant alongside her
principal jill and alan's wife barbara
are also pregnant in only a week every
single woman in the town is expecting
and all of them date from the day of the
blackout an epidemiologist working for
the federal government named susan is
sent to the town to investigate the
pregnancies she offers them three
thousand dollars per family from the
government's side if they decide to keep
the baby most people who are waiting to
abort the fetuses agree to keep them
after learning about the money this is
the 60s after all three thousand dollars
can afford you more than a month's rent
months pass in the blink of an eye and
all the women go into labor on the same
day they give birth to pale skinned and
silver-haired babies who all look like
they could be siblings five boys and
four girls of such features are born but
one of them is stillborn we see dr susan
bring the dead baby to her car she takes
it away to a lab to perform experiments
and hopefully find out the true nature
of the babies for the first few months
everything goes normally since the
babies are not developed enough to
interact but soon jill notices her son
david turning more intelligent with time
when he starts to crawl he can even
spell his own name barbara and alan have
also noticed their daughter mara's
strange behavior they ignore it for the
most part but one day barbara sees
mara's eyes glow the little girl
hypnotizes her mother and makes her dip
her arm into boiling water barbara is
saved when jill arrives at the house but
the incident never leaves her mind she
starts being scared of her daughter so
much so that her thoughts go into a very
dark place hence one day she goes to the
cliff near their house and commits the
unthinkable allen is heartbroken by his
wife's death he knows that mara had
something to do with it but he refuses
to talk about it with anyone meanwhile
dr susan has been observing the children
closely ever since their births she and
the people from the government research
team are in a meeting they discuss the
changes in the behavior of the children
and come to the conclusion that the
increasing accidents and deaths might be
related to them they have also observed
that allen's daughter mara is the leader
they assume she can read people's
thoughts and act accordingly to it but
are yet to prove the theory alan has
long since lost interest in the research
program not wanting to know the truth
about his daughter however dr susan
thinks he can be an asset to the
experiment and wants to bring him back a
few more years pass and the children
grow up even at five years old they are
more intelligent than most adults this
is a small town in the usa though so
that's not surprising they always walk
in a line paired up with their partners
except for david whose partner died at
birth people look at them in the street
and know that they are not normal but no
one is brave enough to cross their paths
one day mara tries reading dr susan's
mind and figures out that she has found
a way to block her thoughts the children
decide to stay aware of her after that
they have to go through monthly health
checkups to ensure nothing significant
has changed in their bodies in one of
those checkups a doctor accidentally
hurts a girl's eye as a result mara
hypnotizes her and makes her pour
harmful chemicals into her own eyes this
causes the doctor to be rushed to the
hospital she does not remember what
happened to her but her eyes are as good
as blind after the incident although
there is no proof everyone in the town
knows it was the kids jill is worried
about her son but she cannot let the
deaths and accidents slide away
hence she suggests that alan teach the
special children away from the rest of
the children in their class alan thinks
there is nothing he can teach them but
jill argues that they have to learn
humanity after the conversation allen
walks to his daughter and holds his hand
out to her however mara simply walks
away she doesn't have an ounce of
compassion in her which allen refuses to
acknowledge at night jill tries brushing
david's hair but he doesn't let her he
claims that there is no need for her to
be emotionally invested in him because
emotions are useless david has been on
tick-tock too much he reads her mind and
finds her thinking about her late
husband the mother and son resonate with
each other because david too lost his
partner at birth looking deep into his
mother's thoughts he finds out about the
word empathy and its meaning the
following day mara and the group are
walking in line as always suddenly david
does something that no one from the
group has ever dared to do he walks away
without mera's permission mara thinks it
is strange but doesn't stop him this
time david goes to the cemetery to look
for his partner's grave there he finds
the woman who had lost the baby at birth
she hates all the special children
because they remind her of the child she
lost she says mean things to david but
he looks into her thoughts and feels
empathy for the first time later he also
meets alan who is there to visit
barbara's grave david reveals that he is
here to visit his partner which
surprises alan because david was never
told about the stillborn as they chat
the kid finds out that alan has also
lost someone important to him he holds
alan's hand acting on his emotional
urges this gives alan hope that special
children can change if taught to have
emotions he agrees to be their teacher
and arranges their first class the next
day while studying anatomy the children
repeatedly say the eyes are the window
to a person's soul alan explains that
they should study that in philosophy but
the kids remain adamant about the answer
he is also surprised by the
synchronization among them when taking
books out or putting them back a while
later the kids are alone when a drunk
janitor comes into the classroom and
threatens to kill them they refrain from
hurting him for some time but as soon as
he touches one of the kids all of their
eyes start to glow the man is then made
to climb a ladder and jump onto a
vehicle the stick he was holding stabs
him in the chest causing him to die
immediately the next day allen goes to
susan and asks her what progress she has
made in her research susan reveals that
their town isn't the only one going
through the same situation in fact
several small villages around the globe
have had blackouts and pregnancies
following them she then brings allen to
a secret room and shows him the infant
that was stolen a long time ago the
experiments performed on the baby have
brought out its original form which is
one of a strange alien creature after
the meeting allen returns home and finds
mara packing her belongings she and the
special kids want to stay in a barn away
from the town she orders allen to bring
supplies for them and doesn't care to
explain further all parents reluctantly
bring their children to the barn scared
of what will happen if they refuse the
following day a man named bill comes to
the barn to meet his daughter he claims
that he has the right to take her back
but the special children do not like
that when he refuses to leave them alone
they hypnotize him and make him crash
his car into a fuel tank at the same
time susan comes to allen and reveals
that the government is planning to bomb
the entire town to get rid of the kids i
would have just busted out the sniper
rifle but to each their own she is
running away and so should allen allen
quickly goes to the children and asks
them to live in harmony if they don't
they will be killed however mara
declares that emotions are for the weak
instead she asks him to bring everyone a
supply box which they will use to move
far away from the town a while later
mara stops david and asks him about his
strange behavior before david can
explain himself the town pastor is
caught in the bushes pointing his gun at
mera the kids kill him as well when it
gets dark the children find dr susan in
the clinic's hallway this time her mask
slips and the group finds out she is the
one who stole the stillborn they take
her to the secret lab and make her stab
herself meanwhile the entire town
gathers outside the barn to destroy it
and retaliate against the special
children but the children attack the
protesters and kill them all in no time
a woman is burned to death after being
hypnotized alan and jill meet each other
and decide that it is about time the
children die because if not others will
allen doesn't want to put jill's life in
danger so he runs away after locking her
inside a room he enters the barn with a
box of explosives the children are now
ready to move but one thing leaves mara
uncomfortable she cannot read alan's
thoughts because he is blocking them
with a wall at the same time jill
arrives at the back of the room and
tries to take david away the children
spot her but they cannot focus on two
people at the same time mara tries her
best to find out what is behind allen's
brain wall just when she sees the
explosives the vision becomes reality
and kills everyone other than david and
jill in the last scene we see david and
jill driving away to a different city
jill is hopeful that they can start a
new life leaving midwich behind but they
probably can't because they just blew up
a bunch of kids subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching